I am Show 2 I became the CEO of tick
tock this guy showed you Tick Tock CEO
shoes Tick Tock CEO Show 2 doesn't run
Tick Tock Shoji choose
I'm serious he's really not in charge of
the company Mr two do you agree that
Tick Tock is controlled by the CCP no
it's so insane that this is happening
all these lawmakers they're just buying
what he's saying we gotta dive into this
okay so the guy every pundit is talking
about right now is named shochu and yes
he is technically the CEO of Tick Tock
but that title doesn't mean what you
think it does in this context the
company has a long and complicated
history that has left it with a
confusing network of ownership interests
this isn't like Facebook where Mark
Zuckerberg has so much Authority that he
can change the name of the company to
meta at the drop of a hat this guy
showed you he's essentially a front man
he can put on a nice suit and go in
front of Congress but he really doesn't
have any actual authority over the
company even though show is technically
the CEO of tick tock there are four
other important figures in this story
these five men have shaped Tick-Tock
into the massive force that it is today
and put the company at risk of getting
banned in the process in order to
understand who's really pulling the
strings of tick tock we have to go back
to the beginning and a man named Alex
Zhu
the year was 2012 and social networking
was absolutely dominant Facebook had
just gone public and one of the biggest
IPOs in Tech History zoc had just turned
28 years old and was managing a company
worth more than a hundred billion
dollars but Alex Jew was older he was 33
at the time he wasn't your typical child
prodigy and he didn't exactly work for a
sexy tech company he was working at sap
a decades-old Enterprise software
company based in Germany yes it was a
tech company but it wasn't a thriving
Hub of innovation databases accounting
systems payroll software this was the
type of stuff Alex was working on but he
clearly wanted more so Alex began
thinking about building a startup back
in 2012 education technology was having
a bit of a moment open courseware like
Udacity and Coursera offered full
college classes online for free Alex
liked the trend of independent online
learning but realized that hour-long
lectures were simply too long and hard
to engage with for for most people no
one was finishing the courses they
started on these platforms so something
had to change and to come by the idea of
Coursera and the idea of a Twitter into
one part making educational accountants
first on mobile bit size show form so we
reduce the barrel to concentration as
well as content consumption for
education and this is where the original
idea for tick tock short video format
came from so he called up an old friend
named Louis Yang and started prototyping
for the first six months things went
pretty well Alex and his team were able
to raise 250 000 from investors and
launch the first version of the app but
once real people started using it things
took a turn for the worse delivering a
feed of video to smartphones was tricky
back in 2014 most social media apps were
still primarily focused on text and
photos the videos took too long to load
and at the end of the day most people
didn't really want to watch educational
content if Alex and his team wanted
their app to take off they would have to
figure out how to get teenagers to love
it so Alex had to start studying user
behavior and change his approach every
day he would ride the train from San
Francisco down south and on that train
he would observe how teens were playing
with their phones one particularly
interesting Behavior he noticed was the
popularity of selfie videos now that
everyone had a smartphone with a
front-facing camera that could take
decent quality video kids wanted to
create more and more content they wanted
to share tricks stunts and most
interestingly lip sync videos
entertainment is going to be much easier
the education because education is
against the human nature and
entertainment is basically following the
human nature
Alex made an important decision now it
was time to refocus and hone in on lip
syncing his company had just eight
percent of their original funding
remaining but the opportunity seemed too
good to pass up now there was one major
competitor in the short form video space
at the time today we're going to be
talking about this brand new app called
Vine
took an Instagram style feed but focused
strictly on six second looping video
clips the app was a massive sensation
and looked Unstoppable at the time but
Alex had a few key advantages first off
vine wasn't focused on lip syncing
videos and didn't really offer any music
related creation tools and second
Twitter had just bought Vine and was
mismanaging the service terribly this
gave Alex and his team an opening so
they moved quickly to launch musically
the app was still Rough Around the Edges
but it was the first app really focused
on music and lip syncing and that gave
it Niche appeal Jimmy Fallon had started
doing a segment on his show where
celebrities with lip sync popular songs
and tons of those clips were going viral
there was even a TV show called lip sync
battle that aired every Tuesday this put
musically in the perfect position to
pull in new users people would watch the
show and then look for apps where they
could lip sync on the App Store
musically would pop up in the search
results and they'd download it it was
growth time after years of stroke
willing to build something popular Alex
had finally found product Market fit
with musically and he was ready to scale
it so the question is how did he grow
the app so quickly
instead of focusing on showing you
content from your social network the
main feed was driven entirely by an
algorithm all that mattered to get
promoted in the algorithm was engagement
if people were watching your videos all
the way through your content would get
shown to more people every major app has
had to lean more and more into this
model but musically was really the first
to fully prioritize algorithmic feeds
this meant that new creators could
quickly gain popularity even if they
didn't have a strong following to begin
with it also meant that users would have
plenty of amazing content waiting for
them whenever they opened the app it
didn't matter if their friends and
family weren't posting anything
interesting but it wasn't just the
algorithm that led to massive growth in
the early years Alex also employed a
second key strategy the Creator fund so
for users typically when they go to a
social media platform the first thing
they're looking for is fair but once
they have the fair
it's not enough
they have to monetize so if the platform
is a platform that can generate most
Revenue stream for influencer that will
definitely stick around this was a
really critical turning point for the
company Vine had refused to pay their
biggest creators and it led to massive
migration from Vine to YouTube Alex
understood that if he could help new
creators actually make some real money
they would stick around and help grow
the platform so that's just what he did
they started paying top creators and
connecting them with advertisers this
allowed new creators to not only get
discovered through the algorithm quickly
but also start making real money but
there was still one more critical trick
that Alex used to grow musically so fast
see there were still plenty of people
who would use musically to create a fun
lip sync video but then go and post it
on another social app like Twitter or
Instagram
so Alex and his team did something
really clever they started watermarking
every musically video that was created
on the platform with the company's logo
and you still see this today with Tick
Tock videos that are watermarked The
Tick Tock logo so that when you share
them on other platforms you know that
content came from Tick Tock by
watermarking the video users on those
other platforms would see musically and
have the opportunity to download the app
these three strategies combine to
supercharge growth and by 2016 the app
had over 10 million people using it
every single day this got the attention
of Mark Zuckerberg who'd already seen
how important buying new hot apps was to
keeping Facebook relevant in 2012 he
bought Instagram and in 2014 he bought
WhatsApp but Zuck didn't just want to
buy musically because they were growing
quickly in the United States there was
something bigger at stake China
back in 2016 China wasn't really a major
political issue yet sure Trump was
starting to saber rattle about it a
little bit but most tech leaders still
saw China as a massive opportunity to
expand their businesses zoc was
determined to crack the China problem if
he could work out a way for Facebook to
acquire musically that would give them a
strong foothold into the Chinese market
Google had failed to break into the
country but Apple was selling plenty of
iPhones so it didn't seem impossible so
he calls up Alex and invites him to
visit Facebook's headquarters in Menlo
Park now at this point Alex has actually
moved to Shanghai to spend more time
with the musically product and
Engineering teams even though they've
had massive success in America the
company is still very entrenched in
China now here is a major turning point
in the story The acquisition talks with
Facebook had fallen apart so Alex was
more or less on his own this is the
moment when music leads was growing like
wildfire in America but his whole team
was based in China so it made sense for
him to start focusing on growing there
once they opened that Pandora's Box they
couldn't close it every content company
in China employs thousands of people to
sift through every post and censor
anything the Chinese Communist party
doesn't like ethical considerations
aside this is a big cost for a small
startup to Bear but it's table Stakes
for growing a social app in China
despite all these hurdles in 2017 Alex
and his team got musically growing in
China the plan was working the app
clearly had International appeal
Facebook had successfully acquired
musically we would be in a very
different situation today no discussion
of banning Tick-Tock no Congressional
hearings no fake CEOs testifying but
then bite dance entered the picture bike
dance is a major part of why Tick Tock
is under so much pressure today and a
big part of why tick tock's CEO actually
has no real Authority now let me explain
how we got here
around the same time that Alex you was
starting to build musically a Chinese
software engineer named Jiang Yi Ming
was starting his own social media
company named bite dance and this third
individual in the chain at Tick Tock
John wasn't focused on short form video
though he wanted to build an app to help
people find interesting news articles
the app basically used a similar
recommendation algorithm to surface the
best news stories on the internet the
tailored to a specific user's tastes and
that recommendation algorithm proved
useful when bite dance expanded into
short for video John could see that bite
dance had created a solid foundation for
growth with their news app and that
video could unlock a much larger market
this but ton of pressure on Alex in the
musically Team all of a sudden they had
one of the most well-funded and fastest
growing Chinese social media companies
breathing down their neck the good news
was that musically was still doing well
in the United States and bite dance was
struggling to get traction there so you
have bite dance dominating over in China
and musically dominating in the United
States it only made sense to combine the
two companies and so bite dance acquired
musically for nearly a billion dollars
but it was money well spent they created
a new combined app called Tick Tock and
asked users to download it and log in
using their existing musically
credentials Tick Tock became the most
downloaded app for iPhones in 2018 and
users were absolutely obsessed they
spent nearly one full hour every day
using the app in just a few short years
Zuck had switched from wanting to buy
Tick Tock to wanting to put it out of
business while our services like
WhatsApp are used by protesters and
activists everywhere due to strong
encryption and privacy protections on
Tick Tock the Chinese app growing
quickly around the world mentions that
these same protests are censored even
here in the U.S that's when things
started to go south Alex you the former
futurist who designed the app he was
gone from the company now Johnny Ming
was running bite dance and had full
control of Tick Tock but things were
about to get more complicated
in January of 2019 an independent
American Think Tank published a report
calling Tick Tock a major threat to
National Security the primary concern
was that Tick Tock because it was now
owned by a Chinese company could
potentially be forced to provide user
data to the Chinese government upon
request
was a huge National Security risk since
tons of military personnel around the
world use tick tock all that data would
flow back to servers controlled by bite
dance Executives who ultimately answer
to the Chinese Communist party now while
bite dance Executives have claimed that
they wouldn't share user data with the
Chinese government the legal reality is
that they may have little choice in the
matter this was a new kind of problem
Chinese tech companies had developed
social media platforms before but they
never reached the scale of tick tock the
key problem is that Chinese authorities
have significant latitude to request
information from private companies
tiktok's privacy policy in America says
the data may be transferred to China and
it's impossible for U.S authorities to
track what happens after it does and
Chinese government overreach wasn't only
a problem for bite dances American apps
back in 2012 when Johnny Ming was still
in the early stage of building bite
dance he came face to face with the
strength of the Chinese Communist Party
see before he launched that news app he
actually launched another product which
roughly translates to profound gags it
was an app to share memes and funny
videos and it was doing really well at
least at first the bite dance team was
able to grow the app to over 200 million
active users by 2018 but then the
Chinese governments shut it down the app
was simply too hard to accurately censor
and the CCP couldn't allow it to
continue now this wasn't really a
massive setback because by then bite
dance had already launched Tick-Tock but
this clearly set the tone for how the
bite dance team would have to operate
going forward the
got his hand slapped by the Chinese
government is telling here we've seen
story after Story of big Tech
billionaires in China going missing
Chinese Communist party has spent the
last decade relentlessly attacking the
local technology sector Xi Jinping took
power in 2013 and since then he's been
extremely worried about tech companies
becoming too influential and straying
from the core values of the Communist
party and this leads us One Step Up In
The Tick Tock hierarchy
let's look at the tools that the Chinese
Communist Party uses to control tech
companies obviously they can pass laws
that control what internet companies can
and can't do in China but those don't
always apply to Chinese tech companies
that operate internationally bike dance
has created International subsidiaries
in the Cayman Islands to allow them more
freedom to operate but there's still
plenty of ways that Xi Jinping can
exercise control over tech companies one
big one is the China internet investment
fund it's basically just a standard
Venture Capital firm they buy small
stakes and tech companies and they've
picked a ton of winners they've invested
in weibo which is China's version of
Twitter they invested in sense time one
of China's leading AI companies and of
course they've also invested in bite
dance but where most Venture capitalists
are in it mostly for the money and want
to own 10 or maybe 20 percent of the
company the China internet investment
fund often buys just one percent the
trick is that the fund is mostly owned
by the cyberspace administration of
China which is their internet regulator
kind of like America's Federal
Communication Commission but that's
where the comparisons end because the
FCC would never make an investment in
Facebook but in China these State
capitalist Venture Partnerships are
increasingly becoming the norm in
America a one percent ownership stake
usually doesn't confirm any benefits
sure you get to participate in the
financial upside but you're unlikely to
really gain much control over the
company not in China though when the
Chinese internet investment fund does a
deal they receive golden shares they
give them board seats and the ability to
make real decisions
has been ramping up these deals like
crazy the share of private companies in
China with state connected investors
Grew From 14 to 2000 to over 33 percent
in 2019. so now even if Johnny Ming
wanted to run bike dance independently
from the Chinese Communist Party he
really couldn't and that leads us up one
more rung on the ladder of control at
Tick Tock a man named Zhang Fu Pang who
keeps such a low profile there's only
one photograph of him online but a
report delivered to the Australian
Parliament identified him as both the
editor-in-chief at bite dance and its
Communist Party secretary his goal is to
transmit the correct political Direction
public opinion guidance and value
orientation into every business and
product line and of course since he
works for the Chinese Communist party
that means he works for Xi Jinping and
this is the heart of the tick tock issue
it's
controls the company since he controls
everything that happens in China and
with increasing tensions between the
United States and China it's easy to see
why American lawmakers are so worried
about Tick Tock the odd thing here is
that they decided to bring in show too a
guy who's clearly not in charge of what
happens at tiktok but now to the really
big question should the United States
ban tick tock
China has banned American social
networks for Years YouTube Facebook
Twitter and more are all banned in China
so it's not like the United States would
be hypocritical in Banning Tick Tock but
America doesn't want to be like China
we're the Free Speech country we're all
about freedom and stopping Americans
from using a particular social network
seems directly at odds with core
American values now this isn't really as
much of a free speech issue as people
think because Facebook and YouTube have
already built direct competitors to tick
tock and are happy to have those
creators move over and ironically the
algorithm that made tick tock so
successful in the first place might wind
up limiting the damage from an outright
ban the concept of followers or
subscribers and really the entire social
graph are much less important on Tick
Tock than other social networks
create amazing content it'll go viral
anywhere so if Tick Tock gets banned
most creators will be able to
re-establish their followings fairly
quickly on YouTube or Instagram many
Tech talkers are cross-posting content
already but it's more complicated than
that it's important to remember how
China controls the internet you can
access American social networks while in
China it's just very difficult and
usually requires a VPN so the simplest
solution might be to just compel Apple
and Google to remove tick tock from the
App Store but still let Americans use
tick tock in a web browser the real
issue with Tick Tock isn't any one
person accessing the service it's only a
problem at scale with a hundred million
Americans using the app regularly the
potential for swaying political opinion
is significant now you're probably
thinking you could say the same thing
about Facebook or Twitter and plenty of
journalists have but those are American
companies run by American citizens that
answer to the American government
Congress can't even get the real people
in charge of tick tock to show up on
Capitol Hill to answer questions and
that's the real risk here
it's simply too naive to ignore the fact
that China is a major geopolitical rival
and is completely unaligned with the
long-term interests of the United States
this wouldn't be a major new power
exercise by the US government either
America has always overseen
International control of American
companies the committee on foreign
investment in the United States or
cypheus reviews every American company
that sells to a foreign country during
the Cold War the Soviet Union would have
loved to purchase one of America's
dominant television networks but that
would have been insane if that happened
there are still risks to an outright ban
of tick tock though it's far from a cut
and dry issue everyone who advocates for
regulation always imagines the
hypothetical perfect scenario but laws
often have unintended consequences it's
entirely possible that the government
goes way too far with the ban it ends up
creating a mess in the process
fundamentally when you're thinking about
The Tick Tock issue it really highlights
the importance of intellectual
flexibility a lot of people get hung up
on this when they let a single principal
guide their entire decision-making
process yes free speech is important and
yes property rights are important but we
have to acknowledge the reality of the
situation the CCP has banned every
American social media app in China and
Now controls the fastest growing app in
America things are completely out of
balance political tensions between the
United States and China are continuing
to escalate you don't have to look
further than the recent restrictions on
semiconductor exports to see how serious
things are getting in order to
understand how the economic battle
between America and China is developing
just watch this video next and really
quickly I'm working on a really cool new
project and if you'd like to be notified
when it goes live just drop your email
at johncogan.com I promise not to spam
you I just want to be able to tell
everyone directly when it goes live I
can't really share much yet but if you
enter your email at johncogan.com you'll
be the first to know about it thanks a
lot
foreign
[Music]